Curb Your Enthusiasm returning people
very excited about very excited yes a
while it's been it's been five years in
five years unbelievable you know and
curb your okay so tributes is coming
back and the Goldbergs new season people
really like they're married last night
weird last night big ratings it's a huge
hit people love it okay I do have a clip
I'd like to show you have a clip you
want to show yeah full okay we didn't
you set up or just show it no just show
it do that
it's self-explanatory I think I found a
blonde hair in Walt's Bronco yeah no I
mean we sort of figured that she was in
the broadcast I'm using the way back
[Music]
can be mine
that wasn't the Goldbergs no no wait you
have to be in a clip to show it
no that's the show Longmire it's
Longmire premiering on Netflix this week
and here's the thing why are you
promoting longer Wahlberg's Goldbergs is
a huge hit huge number three comedy on
TV Longmire needs help I love fire and I
want that show to keep going that's why
I need to promote it so I can keep
watching it okay so check out Longmire
yes and also not then you're not in it
and you have nothing to do with it I do
with it
all right now I do want to like promote
about hey I brought my poster I got a
poster you have a poster I have a poster
okay I have a poster idea what this is
no it's my poster okay see right there
it says to Jeff if this is your poster
that's a hayley lockbox she's in a movie
I just made she um she's a by the way
where's my point why would someone want
a poster of me makes no sense this is my
poster all I said was I got my poster
I'm very excited about this poster so
we're gonna get the word out on what's
your name
Hayley Hayley and longmeyer and mark
Meyer yes
what do this bit didn't work as much as
I wanted it to
I thought this one would work cutter but
by the way a delightful young lady and
and who doesn't want this hanging up in
their home no that's the one I know I'm
I shouldn't have that hanging around the
house let's get ass the Goldberg now
airs Wednesday nights at 8:00 on ABC
huge hit huge Gigantor it's no no I said
truck it's huge but but here's the
difference yeah he's a lawyer yeah
all right we're gonna get you hello yes
I'm not good with political material
yeah I know that you're also terrible
with space work how did that become a
phone you're just it was laying it can
be it way in the 80s this is about the
size of the phone hello yes yes I my
brain is getting a tumor yeah
you